je déclare devant vous tous
que toute ma vie,
qu'elle soit longue ou courte,
sera consacrée à votre service
et au service de notre grande
famille impériale à laquelle nous appartenons tous
qui aurait pu imaginer que les gens
regarderaient un jour cela sur des
ordinateurs portables et  téléphones portables
[Musique]
quand j'avais 21 ans,
j'ai engagé ma vie
au service de notre peuple
et j'ai demandé l'aide de Dieu pour honorer
ce vœu.
Je pense que la principale leçon que nous avons
apprise est que la tolérance
est le seul ingrédient essentiel de  tout
mariage heureux,
ce n'est peut-être pas si important quand
les choses vont bien, mais c'est
absolument vital quand les choses deviennent
difficiles
[Musique]
le concept
décrit si simplement par abraham lincoln
comme gouvernement par le peuple du
peuple pour le peuple
est fondamental pour notre  deux nations
n'est pas une année
sur laquelle je repenserai avec un
plaisir non dilué
dans les mots d'une de mes correspondances les plus
sympathiques,
il s'est avéré être un anus
horribilis
[Musique]
ce que je te vois maintenant comme ta reine et
comme une  grand-mère
je dis du fond du cœur d'abord
je veux rendre hommage à diana
moi-même
elle était un être humain exceptionnel et doué
nous devrions être rassurés que
même si nous avons encore plus à endurer
des jours meilleurs reviendront
nous serons à nouveau avec nos amis nous serons à
nouveau avec nos familles
nous nous reverrons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous aimeriez  un sandwich à la marmelade
j'en garde toujours un pour les urgences
alors je
garde le mien ici
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi